game of thrones is not exactly known for
its morally upstanding characters this
approach means that terms like good and
evil mean very little in the war-torn
fantasy world of westeros characters who
seem honorable and righteous also make
horrific choices and the dastardly
so-called villains occasionally perform
acts of kindness and honor with that in
mind marjorie tyrell played by natalie
dormer has a lot in common with her
peers on the show while always hungry
for power like most characters on game
of thrones she does possess kindness and
understanding that is quite uncommon
among other royalty in westeros still no
one is incapable of making terrible
inexcusable choices and margery is no
different
i am the queen
in fact there's one particular story arc
of hers that some would argue goes way
too far even in this world of murder
betrayal and oppression marjorie tyrell
is originally supposed to marry the
cruel and brutal joffrey baratheon
played by jack gleason however upon his
assassination she marries tommen
baratheon played by dean charles chapman
instead tommen is far kinder than his
brother but more susceptible to
manipulation because of his young age
and naivete margery uses this to her
advantage and emotionally manipulates
the young king into doing everything she
wants it's a truly uncomfortable
relationship and every scene between the
two characters is difficult to watch
eventually after marjorie is killed by
tommen's mother cersei tommen dies by
suicide by jumping from a tower while
it's clear that his mother with her
thirst for power above all else shares
responsibility for this the deeply
problematic relationship between
marjorie and tommen is at fault too the
fact that it ends so tragically is not
only a testament to how realistic game
of thrones can be at times it's also
another indicator of just how grim and
unrelenting the show is when it comes to
killing off its characters so was it
worth it for marjorie the young woman
successfully becomes queen of the seven
kingdoms through her marriage to joffrey
and then thomas but it's quite a short
reign she easily gains control of thomas
who falls in love with her but she can't
beat cersei's manipulations which lead
the faith militant to arrest her brother
loris and then her tommen without enough
knowledge about the world of politics
and how to use his power is unable to
save his wife or handle the emotional
aftermath tommen's history of being
coddled by his mother and abused by his
older brother shapes him into the
innocent and ill-prepared king he
becomes likewise margaery's manipulative
ways are definitely created by those who
raised her in her case the most
influential person in her life is
arguably elena tyrell her grandmother
and the matriarch of the tyrell line we
all know how cunning the old woman is
successfully murdering joffrey at his
own wedding and framing tyrion in order
to get margaery on the throne this in
turn leads to her marriage to tommy you
could even argue that elena is to blame
for marjorie's death although this is
undoubtedly unintentional elena truly
loves her granddaughter and would do
anything to protect her marjorie has
ambitious dreams born from elena's
guidance and she knows how to manipulate
people especially men in order to get
what she wants she's taught that power
and control is the main goal in life no
matter the cost which elena continuously
encourages while marjorie appears to
actually be a good person and care for
tommen she is too blinded by the
influences of her family and the
psychological warfare going on in king's
landing marjorie tries to manipulate
tommen while still keeping him safe
however in the end her own goals remain
the top priority and marjorie uses
tommen as a pawn leading him down the
path to his horrific fate compared to
other characters in game of thrones
especially cersei margery seems like a
saint but is she just as bad as the rest
of them for the death her manipulations
cause or is she also a victim
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]